hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und es ist der letzte tag der
geburtstagswoche hier auch mal was den
meisten von euch hängt mein geburtstag
wahrscheinlich schon aus den ohren raus
aber zum abschluss gibt es noch einen
klassiker 24 dinge die ich in 24 jahren
gelernt habe viel spaß nummer eins du
wirst auch deinen weg oft hinfallen aber
solltest immer wieder aufstehen nummer
zwei die menschen die dich lieben
verstehen sich ohne worte
nummer drei probiere alles aus nummer 4
die besten freunde findest du wenn du
einfach nur du selbst bist nummer fünf
neue dinge lernen macht spaß nummer
sechs wenn dein vater sagt er lässt
nicht los und ist dann doch tut dann nur
damit du über sich hinauswächst nummer 7
wenn ein mensch der nicht jeden wunsch
erfüllt dann ist es nicht weil er es
nicht möchte sondern manchmal war das
einfach nicht kann nummer acht
weihnachten es wirklich die schönste
zeit des jahres nummer 9
deine eltern sind nicht perfekt sie
machen auch fehlern lerne daraus und
machen nicht dieselben nummer 10
wenn du überfordert bis dann drücke auf
die bremse das leben ist kein wettkampf
und muss niemandem etwas beweisen nummer
11 sei dir darüber im klaren was du
kannst nur zwölf dein erster eindruck
von menschen ist nicht immer der
richtige gibt jedem eine chance ihr zu
zeigen wer ist nummer 13 verliebe dich
so oft du kannst auch wenn es nicht
immer gut aus geht es ist das beste
gefühl was zu haben kannst besonders am
anfang nummer 14
herzschmerz und liebeskummer wirklich
nicht umbringen nummer 15 pass auf dich
auf und höre auf deinen körper deine
gesundheit ist es absolut wichtig sohn
kein geld der welt kann da mithalten
nummer 16
lass dir von niemandem einreden dass
wird was nicht kannst nummer 17 hör auf
dein bauchgefühl ist täuscht sich nicht
nummer 18
mit der unabhängigkeit kommen auch viele
verantwortungen nummer 19
such dir deinen eigenen weg und wenn
eher untypisch ist dann ist es umso
wichtiger dass du genau diesen gehst
nummer 20 gehe ein risiko einer
entscheidung werden nicht immer die
richtigen sein aber dafür breit jede
zweite oder jede dritte nummer 21
manchmal hast du einfach glück
hinterfrage es nicht oder überlegt die
nicht ob du es verdient hat
genieße es einfach nummer 22 seine
eigene fernsehsendung ist niemals so
cool wieder einen eigenen
youtube-channel nummer 23 wenn du etwas
wirklich willst lohnt es sich dran zu
bleiben es kann auch viel zeit und
geduld kosten und drei jahre schweiß und
blut und am ende erreichte dein ziel und
er reist noch viel mehr als zehn mal
geträumt hast und nummer 24 der einzige
mensch der dich glücklich machen kann
bist nur du selbst denken nicht dass es
von anderen leuten abhängig ist das
war's ich hoffe ich konnte euch ein paar
gute ratschläge geben und bis zum
nächsten jahr wenn die erstmal nichts
mehr über mein geburtstag höheren
versprochen wenn ihr die anderen videos
von dieser woche sehen wollt hier ist
eine playlist ich müsste jetzt
eigentlich nur jedes jahr das gleiche
video machen und immer nur eine sache
dazu packen ich gelernt habe
oh mein gott wie ich glaube nicht